homeys what is good the left Co show
this week is brought to you by the
Walmart fan shop the ultimate place to
get your goods they got Nike fanatics
majestic I curated a bunch of pieces and
you can find them at the fan shop
walmart.com slash bleacher report check
it out all right ok week two of the
books and I'm wearing the EAG le s I
like that there's a tough loss on Sunday
night no no that was a horrible horrible
loss on Sunday and we're gonna get into
it I'm upset man you really are makes me
not even want to see this but I'm happy
that you ain't we sat down and westbrook
randomly looks up and goes you can't
lose to the Falcons no no this is
compliments of the walmart fan shop you
heard me in the beginning and walmart i
asked them for one more thing so we had
a nice little throwback eagles this is
for you well yeah I would appreciate it
you tell me before the show that I can
get a shirt you know what's tough about
it didn't even bother to give me one no
it's actually for a child and I hear
that you have those I do I do but yeah
they have a shirt with their name on it
and the 36 Thank You Walmart what um
thank you well thank you thank you
welcome the gift that you're the gift
that keeps giving right there uh what's
really funny is is um one time me and my
friend went out and probably I don't ten
years ago in Philadelphia and I know
that he ordered a fried shrimp and the
only reason I remember to this day is
because he ordered a 36 yes in my mind
was a Brian Westbrook home I'll never
forget it good friend of yours I can
tell ya Dan yeah I'll be in the wedding
week to kind of predictable kind of
unpredictable the big news and notes
coming out of it is Drew Brees is gonna
be out for six weeks with a torn
ligament in his thumb and big been out
for the season with an elbow surgery and
I asked you this in makeup could this be
the end for Big Ben and it kind of feels
like I don't see Big Ben rehabbing this
it's almost like in baseball the Tommy
John surgery and guys coming back and
you have to have that fastball you talk
about baseball but for been in that
division
cold weather tough physical football the
way that he plays we he's falling down
all the time yes you know older guy the
only thing that I think that will stop
it from being the the last hurrah for
Ben is that guys never want to go out
injured nobody ever wants to go say hey
my last year I got hurt he wants to come
back and kind of revenge and and tell
people and show them what he is and kind
of finished his career that way that's
the only saving grace I think for him
not playing again Big Ben's first season
ends with a Super Bowl win over the
Seattle Seahawks yeah I kind of got the
feeling that his career just ended week
two against the Seattle Seahawks my
reason is that's what you just said who
Big Ben is no matter what's going on
whether he's gaining weight or he's not
really trying hard he relied on his arm
I mean Big Ben has never looked in shape
his entire career because he would just
go
this thing is unnatural harm Talent and
if that's questioned that's how that's
what he's had that that's been his life
force I don't I don't know man because
this guy has been contemplating
retirement for the last three four years
yeah and I think he kind of sold himself
you know what a lot of a be distractions
and levy on bail and now that they're
done I'm ready to lock myself in for
three more years
I don't know didn't he come into this
year a little bit more refresh that a B
stuff is behind them less behind I don't
think he looks pretty that good no he
did well I think the talent level in
that football team is way down I think
the odds are you've got to him I think
John Tate Moncrief shot the ball and
said I think they'll bow damn oh man
this ball is in your hands catch the
ball but the talent levels down I don't
know how much confidence he had in his
ability to get the ball to these guys
and they actually catch it yeah you took
it took some Pro Bowl players off their
football team and you expect them to go
back out there and do the same thing
it's gonna be hard to do and so I I
would hope to see players not in their
career injury I definitely wouldn't have
want to
my career on the injury especially this
type of injury uh drew brees Saints fans
hate me again because I you don't know
this I've had like a running feud with
the Saints fans last few years because I
like to diminish Drew Brees his career
because I don't think he's a top-five
quarterback of all time and that's
foolish to me I think his statistics are
wildly inflated because he's played in
the dome he's played on multiple seven
and nine teams when like all the other
quarterbacks and histories like never
have losing records and I believe that
also that in the fourth quarter of games
when they're down two scores two raises
the king of like the 90 yard drive for a
touchdown and then the failed onside
kick
to inflate his statistics but I believe
that he's like a top 15 quarterback of
all time and I think he's great and I
tweeted after he got hurt I didn't know
the extent of the injury I tweeted that
man Drew Brees is really jealous of
Teddy Bridgewater being down 14 getting
a pad of stats really that's his spot
they're starting to hate me I don't want
to live on that corner but like every
time I look in the mirror I go that's
who I am
I think Drew Brees about I think he's
way hired I don't you gotta top 15 the
top 10 top 5 I tell you I don't think
it's a top 5 I mean I if you had let's
just say healthy
drew Brees coming into this season you
have this cuff you have seven you're
down let's say you're down six so you
need a touchdown to score any
quarterback in the history of the game
no any quarterback playing right now
okay well then right now is a whole
different discussion okay but I would
pick I pick Brady Brady okay I would
pick mahomes okay
I would pick Aaron Rodgers and VIN
breeze though he's four who else is left
to the NFL they're all hurt yeah well
that's right you up chick air Roger den
breeze but I would take Russell Wilson
over breathe you're out of your mind
what you have to go down and score and
throw the football down the field
drew Brees is one of the most accurate
pinpoint passers in the history of the
NFL yeah yeah I still wouldn't take a
little Russell Wilson you're out of your
mind
yeah pe understands defenses understand
what's coming at them how many tapes of
ours receiver you better let's get to
that because that was the conversation
where I realized your secret hating of
the Ravens secret hating it's okay I'm
team Ravens on the king of the Ravens
fly I'm team
hoorah love John Harbaugh help me get my
career to the next level we're there
were there any moments where you guys
were like John Harbaugh was telling
gonna be a head coach in this league we
know no I'll tell you there wasn't even
those that don't know he was the special
teams coordinator for that for a number
of you and we had like one of the best
special teams units in the league and
it's the hard part about social changes
that when you come into the league you
don't drink about being on kickoff team
over team you dream about being on
offense and defense right and so
everything that you want to do is
involved the offensive side of the ball
toward offense it's the team just like
I'll do that but I really want to focus
back on all right so special teams
coaches hardest job is to get guys that
only you're thinking about offense or
defense focused on offense this is a big
part of the game we had one of the best
specialist teams units in the league and
even then because he was a special teams
coordinator I was like it's nowhere
who'd be a head coach no way one year
they changed him from the special teams
coordinator to the d-backs coach for one
year and I don't think that any of the
d-backs listened to him because he was
the special teams quarterback
coordinator that's who he was
yeah and so after that he got a job I
mean he got a job the very next year
being it head coach somewhere and were
you shocked shocked what do you what did
he prove in that one year being a DBS
coach but then you look at him now well
I'll tell you this this is what he had
attention to detail he understands how
to motivate guys he understands how to
even if you don't understand offense
very well or defense very well he got
the right guys around him he was into an
organization when Ozzie Newsome picking
the players so they were getting some
dogs into that locker room right he went
to a team that had Hall of Famers
already on it Edie read Sheree
Suggs a Ray Lewis so he had some bona
fide yamazaki yet Flacco on his team
already physicians but he had that so he
understood how to rally the troops and
get them to win which he did yeah big
time difference between him and Brian
Billick in Baltimore I just didn't see
that coming from the the beginnings of
him being a special team so it's so
interesting like there's been a guy on
the Chiefs for years Steve talbe yeah
they told taped oh yeah and they they
keep going he could be a head coach and
it's like man being a head coach really
is a rallying of men that's right in a
weird way if you're head coaches like I
spell
so teams guy like Belichick is obsessed
with special teams you have to obsessed
it's the first thing he thinks about it
but what it changes the course of a
football oh yes
harm return that changes the people so
turn your head against the Giants when
you know oh look at you with your memory
alright so I have seven and a half teams
as contenders for the Super Bowl now
really I think I went up one or two but
I also got rid of some okay I'm gonna
let you go first all right and I will i
okay how many teams do you have us in
two three four five six seven okay I
probably had more but this is these are
Lucy one two three four five six
definites in three Possible's alright I
have okay like like a spades hand I got
three definite definition three
Possible's so Plus that means we each
have seven and a half yeah good so so
your most obvious Kasey New England yep
yep initech we know that
Green Bay is inching a little bit
towards that however you have them as a
lockers and maybe I have them as a lock
okay I'm in there too I know I have him
as a lock but I'll tell you this I
wasn't I wasn't that impressed with
their game they scored 21 points early
and then they just fade for the rest of
the game so on it they scored 10 against
Chicago and these are both good deep
very good defense but 21 points and then
if you watch that game Minnesota's
d-line was all around Aaron Rodgers yes
of the game the last three quarters
basically but I will say this they
they're already up to Oh on the Bears
and the Viking huge enormous that's you
and their defense has been unreal yeah
and they get Denver and they also play
Philly on Thursday Night Football at
home so their schedule looks pretty good
today we're both okay so I agree with
you on Green Bay high Seattle in there
for me to beat two AFC North teams now
and also in in the span of which Drew
Brees is hurt and they get New Orleans
at home perfect so one of their hardest
games of the year again schedule looking
out in Seattle two big wins Dallas love
the way the deployers and Brock is on
board I'm excited about the only thing
that scares me as they've beaten the
Giants in Washington yeah I mean you
play Miami next week and then they get
at New Orleans and Drew Brees is out yet
and then Green Bay so this
could be the way I look at it Dallas at
four and oh yeah
taken on Aaron Rodgers and we won't even
know because to be honest they've beaten
Case Keenum Eli they're gonna play Josh
Rosen and then Teddy Bridgewater well we
won't know how good this Dallas defense
is until that Green Bay game but I'm all
aboard the Dallas true thing is is that
we don't know how good they are however
for dak in that offense this is just me
building confidence oh yeah oh I can get
it done all I can make that throw I can
do this I can find somebody deep like we
talked about the contract after Green
Bay game yeah yeah well he better better
figure it out if Jerry Jones gives him a
contract extension after the Miami game
he is dumber than I thought it would
check this out would it they'd beat
Green Bay okay well then you and you got
a pal
and then you got to pay two extra more
per year have you come that's 37 million
you know what if you beat Aaron Rodgers
after what Aaron Rodgers has done to the
Dallas Cowboys in the playoffs you've
earned it alright so now we're at five
so we got five now we're into your
maybes these are all maybes look if we
have the same three teams remaining
who's your most confident most competent
three of the three say it Baltimore
thank you most confident you're a piece
of [ __ ] most confident because they have
a good defense and out I ought to tell
you this teddy bridgewater what voice
was that hey listen
the Carters were in the game last week
yes they were so lettings show with
Warren sharp you'd have learned that
Baltimore's 1 issue is they have issues
with three or more multiple wide
receiver packages well they're in
trouble because I I I'm concerned about
that this is hardcore good defense at
home yeah let Arizona in the rookie
quarterback hang around the guy on the
red zone stops we're gonna learn about
this team quickly at Kansas City this
week that's right game of the week we're
gonna get into Lamar and Patrick moams
later home against Cleveland and then at
Pittsburgh yeah true thing is they if
they lose the Kansas City but beat
Cleveland and Pittsburgh so give him the
North yep there's two good give them the
North I right now Pittsburgh so one to
Cincinnati zone to Cleveland zone one
might we're recording this before mine
in football my next team is Houston
what yes yeah yeah Houston and and this
end not this again this is the question
mark because I think they can win the
south if they win the south right
get a home game never know what happens
just never know if this office get going
they could finally protect Watson they
just put up 13 points the Django defense
that did not have a J Bowie or Yannick
and Gok way yeah they almost lost to
Gardner Minshew
at home and we do hmm I don't have a
buzzer yeah I would like to go home I
just want to let you remind you we just
got finished talking about the Baltimore
Ravens beat the Arizona Cardinals by 6
points thanks I like the house more than
the Houston Texans right now that's a
mistake
it's a last question mark and I probably
should have put this one and I think has
a better chance I think the Rams
yeah they'll come around the Rams sauce
lastly beaten also in my mind the two
best teams
yes far of all the teams on his list
they beat Carolina and the Saints
granted without Drew Brees last question
mark is our Philadelphia I agree that's
it that's the list and I'm so
disappointed that they're still that way
the same teams on the outside looking in
yeah we both have questions about
Minnesota right
you don't think Kirk Cousins is the
answer Kirk Cousins reception was
[ __ ] scary listen they had maybe
three four minutes left in the game
they're probably on their ten or so they
have to drive the field Dalvin cook has
already gone off over a hundred yards
you have feeling you have digs you have
everything that you want as a top passer
in the league and of course you got your
wildest sticking out of the back of your
pockets in it's full of cash eighty four
eighty six million dollars in your
wallet
guaranteed upsets players on the team
like do you think they like they
themselves make 84 million dollar
guaranteed jokes yeah of course you do
yeah why not lindvahl Josas is out there
like destroying people I wish I hate 84
million 84 whatever it is 86 million
well yeah I wish I were bad guaranteed I
mean yeah of course and that was not the
throw than 84 million dollars I'll tell
you this he has an opportunity to win on
routes win on throws and he just he
makes bad decisions the interception and
that's just terrible decision throw the
ball away
it was first down that's what makes it
satyrs that he tried we both that's very
full we both have Chicago on the outside
looking in I don't think we're buying
true Biscay we're not going to Biscay I
knew my new way of talking about your
Biscay is I think he's Carson when
if carson wentz never learned how to
read a defense like if he just went out
there and was like first reads not open
I'm gonna run away I want to talk to you
about that cuz that concerns me about
the Eagles just a bit I'll tell you this
we're gonna get another Sunday Night
Football I'll tell you this I'm watching
Carson and I and I'm studying terrible
first half early first quarter not very
good terrible first happened in general
got much better in the second half but
there's times where I'm saying he
doesn't know when the Blitz has come
where the Blitz is coming from he
doesn't know what receiver he needs to
get the ball to yeah he's like I'm just
gonna break through this sack and then
win it by the time I figured it out
someone will be open and all the things
that we're talking about that dak is
doing right now
yeah defense is slowing down from he
sees it before it happens knows what guy
has one-on-one coverage
I'm concerned that Carson is solely
operating on armed talent and if he can
never put the mental and the arm
together now they got to protect them a
little bit better I say your motto has
to do a better job of front but at some
point you want that did a tall take this
is what they call it they called that
quarterback position to multiply right
how do you make everyone around you
better I know you're playing with
backups and I don't want to hear that
you're good enough you're one of the
best quarterbacks MVP candidate I want
you to make everyone around you better
yeah that that means that's the second
receiver third receiver for receiver I
don't care for Al Sean's out or DeSean
yeah I want you to make those guys who
are inner better yeah Goddard's out to
everybody was up everybody was out was
crazy
I came to you and said man that must be
turf huh like it just makes me think
that Atlantis had one of the most
injury-riddled teams the last few years
yeah and the Eagles go there and like
everywhere implodes it's weird because I
didn't see anything happen to DeSean he
just come to without reading same thing
out Shaun just kind of was like God God
I just stopped coming out yeah like
what's going on my thing with
Wednesday's it's he's so hard to judge
because then he comes to the second half
and he has the one play where he's
falling down and somehow it gets it to
Matt Collins he has that laser to Nelson
Aguilar that a Guillard dropped like
perfect pass yeah but then he has the
play to a galore on third down where
hazard said so many guys the NFL were
just fallen down but he has the
beginning to and I wanted to ask you is
this a Peterson thing it's
seems like once their backs against the
wall the Eagles are a better team
they're better when they're expected to
lose well the first 15 personal day they
like being an underdog we saw that in
the Super Bowl they loved being
underdogs so it's a difference between I
think we talked about it between being
the hunter and the hunted so there's a
different philosophy meaning I play with
the chip of my shoulder
yeah me being the best sometimes I don't
have the same MO the same motivation to
continue to get better so I think that's
part of it the other part that I'll just
jump back to Carson Wentz real quick
he's second way too many hits way too
many hits yesterday there was part of
the game announcer I'm like do not put
them back in the game
I don't care we lose her not he's taking
away it's the second game of the season
attack of a kid taking way too many hits
and so to me again that's him holding on
to the football that's his decision you
have to do a better job these are the
things that after the injury last year
I'm saying he'll come back he's smarter
now yeah he'll do a better job of that
now Doug has got to him is micro Doug
doesn't get creative I feel like with
the offense until they're down 14 points
and then I start seeing like interesting
formations and interesting shots and my
issue with the Eagles too is Jim
Schwartz
they lost by the way Timmy Jernigan for
about a month
yeah with a fracture in his foot so
happy losing Malik Jackson oh I don't
know what's up with that D line but Jim
Schwartz is the perfect defensive
coordinator when you're down 14 he's
going to play aggressive to get you back
in the game yeah he's gonna bring it all
out blitz that leads to two
interceptions by Matt Ryan he's gonna
get you off the field very quickly but
then there's this part of Jim Schwartz
where you're up and it's fourth and four
and you all-out blitz Matt Ryan and it's
like hey let's not do man-to-man
coverage on Julio Jones with no safety
on Tom not with that guy like this is
Matt [ __ ] Ryan yeah we just saw him
throw the ball to our defender seemingly
on purpose sit back in a zone to me that
he can break it down so for me like I
feel the same way I feel the reverse
about Carson Wentz I feel like Jim
Schwartz where there at the beginning
for Carson Wentz I [ __ ] was like what
is wrong with you and then he fixed it
and with Schwartz I'm like thank you for
fixing this and then what is wrong with
well Carson Wentz Doug Peterson first
quarters have been
terrible terrible but I start to
thinking I was thinking about it
yesterday maybe it's the first 15 maybe
Carson is a guy Andy Reid was obsessed
with the first he was being greeted with
the first 30 I think in cases I think
Andy did a great job of saying hey
here's the structure if it's covered -
this way Donovan do you coat throw to
the other side so he was giving them
I think Carson is a type of guy is he
wants to go empty backfield let me see
it for myself I'll figure out what the
best play to put us in and I'll be
successful that's what he did in North
Dakota when things get rolling they go
two minutes they go no huddle Carson is
boom-boom-boom-boom-boom
getting the ball out to me that early on
in the game first of all I don't think
Carson's in the rhythm and I don't think
Doug as a play caller isn't a rhythm and
as the game goes on when they figure it
out the Carson moves around a little bit
but I'll tell you this again the biggest
concern coming into the season was
Carson Wentz in his health all those
shots that he took last night I'm more
concerned about him now than I've ever
been ever been and he played great in
the second half but he took an awful lot
of shots um my Super Bowl meter last
week was a 6.4 what was yours five would
I point out as yours now it goes down
it's 4.5 4.5 goes down yeah it goes down
I'm a five point one five home win ok so
long Jay you went down a bunch so what
did you see what did you see
particularly from the defensive side of
the ball that made you say because I
think offensive that made me say what
made you say hey maybe this team is not
good enough
a lot the fact that like I feel like
unless they brought in all-out blitz
they didn't get any pressure on mattre
front force in fact that all of their
quote like Andrew send a hell it looks
like he's running a 5 flat 40 very slow
the fact that I'm looking at Rasul
Douglas and we have I feel like we have
five guys that are Asante Samuel without
the town of Asante Samuel like I feel
like we have five guys are like I'm
gonna jump this round and it's like
Ronald Darby is fast enough know what
but he's coming off an offseason surgery
my goodness I mean he ended up giving up
the touchdown
yeah the other two that were just missed
I'm concerned about I'm very concerned
I'm in Sydney Jones it's a hit then he's
the only other teams that we must have
had on the outside looking in Chargers
just a lack of depth
I'm not including the Saints and the
Steelers right now because the
quarterback injuries and Buffalo is
interesting but I'm not ready to play
they're not enough do you think the
Chargers are in any way saying you know
what maybe we need Melvin go home no way
because also actually quite well just
attack did they both play it well so
there the Chargers lost the game at the
Lions usually loose there was one drive
in the third quarter
where the Chargers Austin Eckler had a
50-yard touchdown it was called back due
to a penalty yeah Justin Jackson like
three plays later had a 50-yard
touchdown on that call back they drive
down the field and then Austin Eckler
fumbles on the one that's right so like
I look at the Chargers and I actually
feel more confident about the Chargers
after week two than I did in week one
because they just got they just got
screwed by some penalties and stuff yeah
III hate teams that lose the game and
win the turnover battle I mean that to
me there's no excuse for that
they got they forced two interceptions
by Matt Stafford
there's no excuse to win to lose that
game against the Detroit Lions team
that's just not quite as Talent I
mentioned the bills I would say the two
surprised teams that are two and out
bills and 49ers yeah of those two teams
who do you see being more successful in
the long run well I first of all by
stocking
I like the 49ers much better because two
things I like their head coach and I
think they have a funny weird group of
running backs that actually all fit with
their head coach wants to do and I think
Jenni me Jimmy G he'll continue to get
better as a player but here's the thing
Matt Breda in a weird way I watched him
all last year yeah catches the ball well
out of the back there runs the ball well
credible back mosters oh they're almost
the same guy you look at me you figure
you're the same guy they run the ball
will they catch the ball well at the
back Hut runners I remember when I was a
free agent got cut by the Eagles went
down to Washington
I met with Mike Shanahan he was kind of
like I'm actually I've met with Kyle
first he was like listen we're on the
board we can use he in this formation we
can get you out catch the ball out of
the back though we can use in the
backfield on this draw play all these
different things right this pre rg3 yes
this pre rg3 Clinton Portis was still
there Donovan was a quarterback that
year yeah they bring me in and so cows
like
drawing up all these different things we
need you in our team I go to meet with
Mike and Mike with his dad he was like
yeah we don't need you got couldn't
Porsche we don't need you at all I was
like well I just talked to your son
literally two minutes ago
he said you need me he was like yeah we
don't and so but I I would say that
because as I'm watching Matt Breda and
moster I was like these guys are doing
exactly what they had say on the board
yeah they told me to do with that on the
board but they paid Jerick McKinnon to
do just these exact things so I think
that office certainly has an opportunity
they've scored 72 72 points in the first
two games of the season
and they don't even have Tevin Coleman
right impressive impressive so what what
was he saying to you on the board like
what were what were the styles that when
you watch TV now you're like that was it
well yeah it's it's basically you're
forcing the defense to get you to get
the advantages that you want okay we're
gonna put this guy in motion we'll put
the receiver in motion so now the back
is all by himself on this one side with
the tight end and the linebacker yeah
the safety has to check the the tight
end that means the running back is
one-on-one with the linebacker you
designed the place to get the exact
matchup that you're looking for and it's
been pretty dog more good I'm gonna
mention one more thing about San Fran
next two games at home so the first two
games of the season we're on the road
next two games at home at Pittsburgh
who's averaging 14 and a half points a
game at Cleveland I mean see me at home
there at home but yes Pittsburgh who's
averaging 14 points a game then a bye
week and then and then Cleveland who's
averaging 13 yeah nothing again so I
mean these are pretty good it's so good
on
Twitter of Kyle Shanahan's play calling
in the first half he had the first
touchdown of marques Goodwin where it
was a play-action naked bootleg and
Goodwin ran right along the backs of the
D lineman so the whole defense lost wide
open yeah later that same quarter Jimmy
Garoppolo has four wide receivers go out
and the running back kind of shoots out
the side and the center west and
Richburg runs out yeah leads the way
Jimmy Garoppolo had 77 yards passing in
two touchdowns and didn't throw the ball
further than five yards like that's how
great Kyle Shannon is at designing stuff
and what you were saying is what the
Kyle Shanahan Mike Shanahan hole offense
is we're gonna move the whole line right
we're all
moving right because what we're gonna do
is you're gonna have to run with us and
if you don't then we're like we have all
the advantage good and as soon as you
start running with us we need a running
back with good eyes to find a lane so
they're just waiting waiting waiting
you're too slow I'm hitting a gap and
most hurts that kind of guy they sign
that other guy Jeff Wilson junior that
guy Raheem most hurt but what happens is
is what Kyle can then do is we're all
running this way well guess what bootleg
George Kittel that's right and and he
has the number one amount of oh [ __ ]
plays in the NFL where the defense is
running and they go oh [ __ ] that's right
that's Kyle shanty how's the backdoor
didn't even know you there but I will
say this of those two I'm going Buffalo
as the team I'd rather buy so Buffalo
they both have an interesting
circumstance Buffalo played both of
their games at MetLife San Francisco
beat Tampa Bay and then stayed on the
East Coast and went to Cincinnati
right so they both had two road games
which we the apparently Warren said the
the odds of those teams actually winning
the second game is like 15 at 20% right
both have quarterbacks that were
questioned this off season Josh Allen
was questioned for his accuracy Jimmy G
question because of his preseason
performance the Niners as you said not
only did they have 72 points the first
two weeks they've had four touchdowns
taken away by the referees so that just
shows you like they could be putting on
even more they also have seven sacks in
the first two games this defensive line
that they haven't had anybody with Nick
Bose and Orick arms tend divorce Buckner
both Andy Dalton and Jameis Winston have
been running for their lives Matthew in
the first two games the thing that does
concern me is that they've scored on
Tampa Bay and Cincinnati last year Tampa
Bay was 27th in the NFL on defense last
year Cincinnati was 32nd the NFL and
defense and they just lost their
starting left tackle Joe Staley for
eight weeks
that's my concerns with the bills
they're a powerful team they know
exactly who they are they have a
quarterback that is a special ability
and they play the Miami Dolphins twice
yeah and that doesn't matter to me that
doesn't matter that matters top so then
they're gonna get Sam darn 'old may be
coming off mono
negative they've played two teams
without a deep passing game so Buffalo
right now has played Eli Manning and Sam
darn 'old and I that's my only question
about Buffalo is when a team can really
go deep because that defense loves to
keep you in front what happens then and
then my other question about Buffalo is
who's the playmaker on this team other
than Josh Allen John Brown is really
fast right he's not a third down and
eight I gotta have it go know they have
some running backs that I love but none
of them are got like guys I could do it
all by themselves
I love Devon singled I think he's gonna
be really good there they're giving him
giving him responsibility and they just
don't have like young baller when you
need a guy that's my concern with them
well yeah I mean the big time questions
for them obviously they're gonna have
some issues in that division just
because the Patriots are there we all we
understand yeah but if guys keep getting
hurt in Pittsburgh and in in in New York
they may have a chance they keep winning
the outside you know playoff spot by the
way with Pittsburgh going down my Ravens
pick is looking sweet it does look good
well we'll see we'll see we'll see how
the Browns respond this week we'll see
that T well we will see how they respond
how many teams have you already
eliminated from contention for the Super
Bowl in the NFL yeah I don't want to say
that they're dead right but not yet you
can't say they're dead no I'm gonna say
these teams are dead
well I they're I have five and a half
five and a half see I have some I have
some I have one two three four five six
seven oh you have more dead than me and
I'll tell you what's obviously Miami
everybody some pretty dead I think and
you may have confidence in Teddy
Bridgewater I don't see you think the
Saints are dead organic sweet without
Drew Brees Wow I think the Saints are
dead without Drew Brees I saw Teddy
Bridgewater yesterday I think he could
be accurate
similar to Brees I don't think he showed
that yesterday I think that he struggles
to throw the deep ball and that concerns
me
always that concerns me at some point in
the league you gotta go deep we're
talking about the first week of season
but these big-time cordovan Aaron
Rodgers
since in particular they opened things
up with the deep past that's one of the
things that the Eagles didn't have
yesterday because DeSean Jackson was on
the sideline in turn how someone would
argue that Drew Brees is the the biggest
thrower if he never was but he was so
accurate he understood what defenses
were giving him he's able to take that
and I'm not saying teddy bridgewater
teddy bridgewater isn't as cerebral
Andrew Brees we haven't seen but it's
impossible for Teddy Bridgewater to be
giraffe in this offense Newbery's I
think to your point is I've always
thought that the Saints roster is a
little shallow mm-hmm below Alvin Kamara
and Michael Thomas right I mean now
we're into tray Quan Smith Ted Ginn jr.
Jared Cook has got some spark too but
I've always thought that Drew Brees his
ability to change the line at the scrim
at the line of scrimmage teams played
the line of scrimmage or read the
defense has what's given them an
advantage to overcome that and I don't
think they can do that with Teddy out
and I'll add this one thing and I didn't
think I was gonna be saying this I'm
wondering the question to me you're out
there you're an order is Alvin Kamara oh
is he able to carry the load the entire
load oh I thought you're gonna say
should they play Taysom Hill at
quarterback no are you crazy no that's
not what I got it I'm wondering kick any
carry the low vision issue we know they
should not they um they want to throw
him the football we know that they want
to get involved in a run game but he was
much better one-two punch with Mark
Ingram so that's a big question
miss Allen on their town on their roster
without Drew Brees I think Davis Murray
by the way is the king of the gets off
the bus and you go oh my God he's felt
like Adrian Peterson and then he runs
and you go he doesn't run hard no no
alright so Washington Washington's dead
Washington's did I think the Wayne
Haskin has to play pretty soon
pittsburgh's out of there it's funny
that was like with keenum it's like
they're still putting out like they're
putting up numbers you see a scary Terry
on a touch I did see that I saw that
scary touch a guy he's [ __ ] great
they're playing for behind so I mean
curse they're gonna have some yards but
and then when they put Haskins and they
played at Ohio State - yes [ __ ] Haskin
has a huge arm future I loved him in the
preseason even made some mistakes with
the interceptions but I think he'll get
better so I'm not putting Haskins out
there until Trent Williams comes back
should waves not come I know here's the
team now 1.2 million dollars
let me let me rephrase that I think
troop Wiggins may come back because he
doesn't have to pay that money but
they're not apparently gonna cut him a
deal
he's no they're not gonna cut him a deal
but he he does he's gonna have to pay
the money but he'll be getting more
millions just for being back of course
so right now that one and a half
whatever is 1.2 that's coming out of his
bank account
yeah not money that he's getting for
their seeds one or this if I got fined
by a team yeah and then I got cut do I
still need to pay the fine yes
[ __ ] yeah paid got paid no but this
but if even if it's not an a-league
mandated fine like if the league finds
me I have to pay the league for a hit
right but if a team finds me never being
late
got a pin I'm fired if I see if I
transfer high schools I don't have to
serve detention at my new house well if
I'll give you a perfect example when I
was in college I probably racked up I
don't know $34,000 where four parking
tickets over four years as an all-time
leading raju the way you made school do
you do you just your parking tickets are
forgiven can I tell you no let's see
I'll let you know but you amazed that I
think I owe the city of Syracuse I'm
sure you do
that's my point that's they don't just
disappear so I don't visit your RV so it
would be immediately so Pittsburgh why
would you bring up such a troubling I
know that just wanted a because I know
that a lot of people have parking ticket
and they're old schools
why haven't you come back to see us it's
not you I'm scared it's the police yeah
I got to get over there so yeah so
Pittsburgh without Big Ben Pittsburgh
this doesn't have the talent so you had
them eliminated too
yes you know what I did this before
knowing that Big Ben was out for the
season and they're done with Big Ben I
was concerned about Pittsburgh you don't
have faith in Mason Rudolph no no no I
don't obviously pick Big Ben I'm gonna I
think that's Berg is dead I think James
Conner is a good running back I don't
know that he's healthy right now the
other part to that is it's not look good
at all I don't think no he doesn't it's
a different world you take away one of
the best receivers hitta came it's a
different world plane I experienced it
with tou take him away now I'm facing
instead of four minutes five minutes six
seven K did you realize is a different
[ __ ] game immediately when he's not
there so like the first game the OTO
did he go to afterwards going to Dallas
yeah yeah well yeah I mean you know TL
and he was out for a couple he was like
first play know it's kind of like well
what's that safe you doing down here
because instead of seeing a guy had 12
yards 13 14 yards you see him at eight
and so now the first time that you meet
in that type of contact you know five
six yards in the backfield he's eight
yards deep so we're meeting maybe two
three yards around the line of scrimmage
instead of five six yards down the down
the line you can get a little bit of
steam that's a different feel yeah I
mean so it's a little bit different so
not having you know you're eliminating
the Giants Turin Giants out of their
hands are dead doctor you killed the
Denver Broncos I didn't say the
different no I didn't say I am Denver
Broncos are dead
no Arizona's out of there Joe Flacco
love an ass out of here you don't know
what are you talking about how about
there oh one and one yeah and then they
have a chance to do what again are we
talking my teams that have no chance at
winning the Superbowl
I'm talking yeah in Arizona and your
mine has a chance of winning Arizona has
more of a chance than Denver that can t
make the playoffs you just talked about
San Francisco just because they're the
only team in the NFC West that isn't to
a node right now I don't have this
[ __ ] okay you're listen sorry hi
owner Detroit is out of there Detroit
his dad Detroit's out of there get out
of here yeah this works out of there one
in one out then I'm an Italian so today
Westbrook has killed Detroit Detroit
South and Arizona Arizona out and I'll
tell you this
Cincinnati dead Cincinnati's dead I
don't know how long Sam d'Arnaud is
gonna be out for the season sir my half
because out of there if you're out of
there and they play into the same
division as your team the bills and of
course the Patriots they're out of there
all right so who else did you see you
killed Miami Cincinnati Pittsburgh
Washington Giants the Jets the Saints
Detroit in Arizona I have one more team
that I didn't want to put in the game
you got like ten I got one more team
that I did not want to put in there but
I put him in there because my eyes were
telling me something
it's the Los Angeles chargers my eyes
are telling me that they're not good
enough you believe after week two yeah
hello Los Angeles Chargers have no
chance
one in the Super Bowl yeah you feel
really confident about I feel good about
that because last year I felt that they
had a legitimate shot I'm talking about
the run past threat with Melvin Gordon
in the backfield
then you had and he had Jackson and
Eckler back they're both good players
you had Tyrell Williams you have my
Quinjet kina they had a bunch of ballers
on that football team and somehow a
playoff they just gotten up ended I
don't know that that team rebounds it
comes back even stronger this year I
think they have less talent this year
than they had last year
they're decimated with injuries the
entire defense is is seemingly on injury
reserve they just lost honor Henry they
don't have Melvin Gordon Derwin James is
on IR they got Michael Davis on the
injury sheet every week it's so you
think they're done done how do they come
back I mean injuries hurt you obviously
we know that Kansas City is the is a
prize of that division we understand
that but where do they come back to are
they just gonna magically get better
healthier sometimes I I just think it's
you believe in magic I just think it's
amazing that you're willing to say the
Chargers are dead but you're not sure
about the Broncos yeah
you got you good now you're done with
the Broncos yeah I can I could put the
Broncos on there to it listen there's
one thing that you never do I didn't
want to write off and that's put 20
teams in a Joe Flacco bro yeah [ __ ]
wrote off 11 I'll probably have more
next week and that's the truth about
this is that we say that you can't
figure it out for two weeks you can't a
lot of times you can yeah now look there
the Colts last year started off Owen -
and then ripped off 11 straight but that
was also because they had a special
player at quarterback Andrew Luck and
that offensive line kind of came
together and their defense started
playing lights out I am he doesn't have
that no Denver doesn't have Pittsburgh
just lost it Washington doesn't have it
the Giants don't have it the Jets have
mono the Saints just lost it the Lions
I'm not as bullet the Lions and
Cardinals I'm not touching huh I'm not
touching we're talking about a Super
Bowl - doesn't mean they won't even have
a winning season either one of those
teams we talking about
there are definitely not Super Bowl
contention neither one of those teams
yeah Oakland I could say this is funny
Andy Andy Dalton is the leading passer
in the NFL right that is funny
that's because the team is always losing
they lost by what 21 24 this past
weekend man just eliminated half a
league so of the on2 teams that I think
are the most surprising there oh and two
it's Carolina and the Steelers with the
big banner injury are we willing to say
that the Steelers are done yes they're
done done not enough talent I think juju
is good I don't think he's great I think
Andrews great you think so okay I think
that well I think when you don't have
another wide receiver with like Donte
Moncrief and James Washington dropping
balls in your quarterbacks Mason Rudolph
he's not a great anymore I think I think
over time he may develop into great I
think he's good I think he's actually
really good but I don't know that he's
great I think James Conner saying I can
be say the same thing about him I think
he's good I don't know that they're
Steelers cuz when I'm thinking of the
Steelers I'm thinking a running nasty
downhill football team that's that's not
what they were oh I looked at the stats
- probably a couple weeks ago it was
like since week nine of last season they
haven't had a back over 80 yards Wow
you know say it was something crazy like
that for James Conner I just I don't
they're not that team that we thought we
they were the other part is that I think
last year they were 31st in the league
and rushing the Pittsburgh Steelers
where they run the ball down your throat
and then play action over the top that's
not what they do anymore the other part
is that their defense that's not the
Steeler defense that I grew up knowing
that was my issue is you've allowed 61
points in two games but the positive is
that it's two true Super Bowl contenders
in New England and Seattle but this
Keith Butler defense yeah
Warren Sharpe the guy that does the show
with me on Thursday is Brian like he has
been saying for the last three years
Keith Butler's defense is awful they
constantly leave linebackers on slot
receivers mister and the good offensive
coordinators in this league have torn
them up yeah because there's talent on
that Steelers defense Stefon chew it in
Javon Hargrave and Cam Hayward and and
Edmond Hayden and TJ watt like they've
got ballers but the scheme always seems
to be all over the place well look at
their stats this is their defense 27th
in points they given up 30 and a half
points again 29th in yards given a 445
yards
game 29th in the past 320 yards again
pretty hard to do in 21st again to rush
on it so not only are they bad in the
past they're also bad mean they're bad
across the board so if if you had a
defense let's just say you had a defense
that was like Jacksonville yeah they're
gonna be great against the pass but
maybe they're not so good against the
run okay and I think Jacksonville is
probably a bad example but because
they're usually good above against both
but if you're a defense you got to make
a team pick their poison right now if
you play Pittsburgh you like yeah we
don't have to pick our poison we can run
the ball a little bit we could pass the
ball a little bit we go back to the run
yeah do that a little bit more what uh
what about the Panthers my positive is
that they play in the AFC South and that
means they're gonna get Brees with this
injury yeah they're gonna get another
shot at Jameis later and that's very
winnable and the Falcons kind of look
all over the place they also play
Washington which feels like a win they
had a chance to win both of the games
they've been in so far the Rams in the
box a lot closer than the standpoint of
they lost to the Bucs man and if you
really look at the games the Bucs had
289 total yards and Jared Goff did
nothing against the Panthers my issue is
cam looks awful and it's really hard for
me to buy into the Panthers when Cam
Newton is doing this like rifle up for a
12 yard pass that isn't even on the
money I just don't see it we talked
about not seeing something I don't see a
good cam right now cam obviously still
hurt
I mean we we see the last play of the
game offensive play with the little
trick play to to you know end up with
the McCaffrey with the ball going around
cam is obviously obviously still hurt
last game 51 passing attempts you can't
win that way no not this office not with
the quarterback that's coming back from
ankle injury and shoulder injury you
can't win that wing four straight games
without a TD pass is it really wow
that's crazy I mean that's absolutely
crazy we know that he's injured I went
back so before the game I went back and
I was just looking at the numbers one
third and fourth down cam they've had a
hundred and fifty three rushing attempts
cam has just by himself 122 of those
rushing attempts he gets the first down
seventy nine point seven percent now
let's go back to the game where is for
Fionn inches
65 250 260 he didn't want a toss to
McCaffrey I did like a toss sweep out
and I still think McCaffrey has to put
his foot in the ground and try to run
the guy over to get the first down but
either way I just don't know how
everyone doesn't watch the Patriots and
see Tom Brady sneak on every third and
fourth and one and go let's copy and
it's obvious to me it's just like it's a
no-brainer yeah yeah we're gonna we're
gonna sneak it in this is the guy that's
gonna do it and we've seen it on tape
and that's what they're gonna do sighs
this I think the Panthers offensively
are gonna be in trouble because cam is
is injury maybe he gets healthy but even
if he gets healthy which I think is
gonna be hard because he's taken so many
doggone hits yeah I don't know that they
can still compete I just don't know how
they play this week Super Bowl contender
Arizona ooh
that may be a good right get healthy
time that should be interesting
cam right now on the season negative two
rushing yards amen
and usually like that's a Jared Goff
style that's not a game kneeling down to
win the game that's not the Cam Newton
but there are probably in my mind four
quarterbacks that are seen as the best
of the NFL rainin after two games dak
Prescott Russell Wilson Lamar Jackson
Patrick mahomes okay Lamar Jackson and
Patrick mahomes are the two that I
really want to focus on because to me
what their numbers have been crazy so I
have some stats and I want you to tell
me if it is fact or fiction okay okay
Lamar Jackson and mahomes are two of
three quarterbacks the NFL averaging
over 10 yards per pass mahomes yes yes
both both fact fact indeed dak Prescott
is the third dak mahomes and Lamar
Jackson are combined 14 touchdowns no
interceptions
14 sounds like a lot but Lamar I had
five with the first week fact fact they
are both seven touchdowns no
interceptions all right that's
impressive because again Lamar Jackson
was not a passer last year he was a
running back but for him to come out
seven touchdowns no interceptions even
though he played some of the weaker
teams still
after two weeks Lamar Jackson is a
higher quarterback rating than Patrick
mahomes factor fiction mmm fiction yes
you are all facts I wanted to I you know
this is like in college right so you got
a it can't fit out see on your scantron
yes the last answer is there but it has
to play it keep yeah you got to play the
game so Lamar right now is QB rating is
a hundred and forty five point two
mm-hmm mahomes one hundred and thirty
six point three DAC is one forty two
point nine that's why I don't want to
leave Jack out of it but mahomes has two
hundred and twenty five more passing
yards than Lamar but Lamar has 125 more
rushing yards than mahomes of those two
Lamar and mahomes who right now it would
be your MVP thus far the season through
two games Most Improved Lamar MVP passer
my own gotcha
easy but this is what I've seen from the
Mar in that offense right they were
coming out of the goal line so usually
in this type of situation with the
quarterback that you're not so confident
in you run the football because you
don't want him dropping back in the end
zone and potentially get a a holding or
him running around gets tripped his
bumble set a safety or a touchdown
they're throwing the football are you
talking about the first drive he ever
here yeah yeah yeah I remember that
they're like a 40-yard stroke no I mean
he have so much confidence in and so the
same thing I was talking about with
Carson Wentz for quarterbacks a slows
down just a little bit and you start to
say okay the safeties are moving the
Blitz is coming from this side I need to
throw the ball to this side
Oh the Safety's going the other way I
need to throw the he's throwing to wide
open people because he's seen it
different you add this week 120 yards
rushing it's a different world now now
if you're the defense you can't win you
literally can't play the right defense
because you can't account for a
quarterback that can throw and run
what's impossible about last week we
said what did Lamar Jackson put on film
he put on five rushing yards yeah and
all those passing yards and we said now
all these teams are gonna drop back and
watch Lamar run you need 120 yards
Lamarr is reaching like mahomes can
throw it to positions that we've never
seen people be able to hit before yep
so he's expanded how far the defense has
to go back because he can throw a back
foot 50-yard laser no problem Lamarr is
challenging you horizontally and
vertically and also it's it's becoming
an 11 on 10 yeah and you experience this
early on with Donovan where mm when
Donovan had like 600 rushing yards teams
didn't know what to do it couldn't
handle him and Lamar is like 10 times
faster than Donovan
he's like a running back know when you
see him with the ball he is a running
back yeah I mean he's making people miss
he's fast he's quick a lateral agility
the great thing that I've seen it with
with Lamar this year is that he's
understanding defense we talked about
that but he's also going through his
progression first guy isn't there I'm
going to the second guy second guy isn't
there I'm going to the third guy and he
has poise in the pocket pocket I kind of
contrast it to Carson there was a couple
of times in the past game we locked on
one receiver yeah in lock door locked on
locked on in time that he got off he
didn't have time to go to the second
receiver because the pass rush was
getting him Lamar understands that hey
first guy isn't there okay I'm off of
him second oh he's not there maybe I'm
running at this point that's why he has
so many rushing yards but that's
something that you don't learn you know
you don't master it in offseason
normally he looks like thus far that
he's mastered that position which to me
Bo's very well for the Baltimore a and
if I'm going to compare those four
quarterbacks you know Russ playing
Cincinnati and Pittsburgh
Cincinnatus defense is really not that
good and Pittsburgh we saw it can get
torched up now back-to-back weeks I look
at dak Giants Washington not that
impressive when you look at it when you
do mout Lamar Miami Arizona not that
impressive but when you look in the
homes yeah and he goes to Jacksonville
in a game that Vegas was pounding the
jaguars a Jacksonville team that without
one of their best corners and without
their best pass rusher held the Houston
Texans great offense to 13 and then goes
plays Oakland that looked dominant the
Monday before and you realized that
Patrick mahomes did this without Tyree
kill yeah with DeMarcus Robinson and me
Cole Hardman
and his starting left tackle Eric Fisher
out most of the game and he put out like
300 yards in the second quarter I still
will say it
Patrick mahomes was the greatest
quarterback that I've ever seen play
I've never seen anyone do what he's done
and whenever I say that they start
talking about rings they start defining
the word great we got this you know that
you have to factor in longevity a little
bit when you talk about greatness
I [ __ ] hate the word great my home is
the most you lose did you decide use the
most talented quarterback I've ever seen
okay I can go with that you can go with
that I can go with that it's just like
go over the course of two years who are
you talking to that talks like that who
says that what's one of these old guys
you hang around in the barber shop
what about Johnny Unitas he really
thought about people well lastly I'll
mention this about our Baltimore Ravens
thank you they are mine
four minutes left Arizona Cardinals had
the ball they had an opportunity to win
do you realize that me and Warren sharp
were so upset because one of our big
bets of the weekend was Baltimore
Arizona over and really all we needed
was a touchdown and Arizona kicking
three field goals inside the five that's
what all you want and Baltimore is there
inside the five
and Neal's it at the end of the game
mm-hmm I'm saying they haven't
opportunity nine minutes left scores 17
to 20 2017 oh absolutely so I mean but
but Kyler also looks phenomenal kind of
had 350 yards passing Kyler had some
plays to Cristian Kirk and Larry
Fitzgerald look this is the thing is
people don't realize they go oh we've
seen gimmicks come to the NFL and not
work before yes Steve Spurrier
eventually we figured out Chip Kelly's
offense all this stuff realize that
Arizona is playing four wide receivers
they're playing tenth David Johnson no
tight ends four wide receivers I'm
pretty sure the last two years Seattle
and LA have faced that formation like 40
times in the last two years teams are
not used to seeing this so the Cardinals
are gonna have these first few weeks
where there's not enough tape but also
they have a quarterback that we haven't
really seen Cuyler run
yet and he's not gonna write waiters
yeah but I'm waiting for a team that
forces him to that drops everybody back
and goes we don't think you're gonna run
that's gonna be an exciting I'll tell
you what disappoints me about the
Cardinals and they were in the game for
the most part all game long you know it
was six to 1717 six and a half time is
David Johnson I mean what's going on
they paid him a bunch of money he got
hurt in the first half and he walked off
with like a limp arm and he came back
and he looked okay I know that I was
excited after week one cuz they were
really that's right when you over the
place all over the place they had the
same no he's not the same guy you wonder
if he's built physically wise to be able
to do catching and in running out of the
bag he's a big guy he's a big guy and
the guys that do that yeah they used a
little bit smaller i right now do you
know Peyton Barbara or the Buccaneers
would you rather have Peyton Barbara
Devonta Freeman that's a legitimate
question and I can't believe I'm asking
I think but you watch Devonta Freeman on
Sunday night yeah I watched him and I
feel like Peyton Barbour is Peyton Bobby
has played better he's the guy he's your
I guess I'll start baton barber he's
played better I for some reason past
history makes me want to say Devonta
Freeman is better and past history is
what I use in running backs to realize I
don't want to use them yeah I kind of
feel like Freeman is better but based on
what I've seen this season Barbour has
played better isn't that while there I
just realized there's the picture behind
you that Nikki Jie put instead of Eli
Eli isn't it let me so Pat Shermer came
out this morning a Monday morning and
said I'm not willing to to say that Eli
is going to be the starter and then the
reporter followed up and said do you
realize that that might cause a
controversies as I do now I believe the
shake I believe that Pat Shermer has
been trying to get Daniel Jones to start
since the preseason but the owner John
Mayer has come out a few times to be
like we are starting Eli Manning really
I believe that the Giants are running an
offense that's made for Daniel Jones and
just showing that Eli is not able to run
it Wow but why would he holder say that
because I thought about this it's the
same thing with Bob Kraft talking about
Tom Brady except Tom Brady has
six elias two for about two decades this
has been his guy when his kids when John
Mayer his kids were growing up they got
Eli Manning signatures yes when it was
time for the for the Giants charity
auction Eli Manning was the guy that was
there they experienced Super Bowl
championships together he was able to be
friends with Peyton Manning and Archie
Manning because of it I think what
happens is is these owners look at these
quarterbacks as their sons and I think
that they kind of think in their head a
little bit that I guided him a little
bit and it's the hardest connection to
break which is the father-son connection
yes and I think that's what's happened
with the Giants is that Mehra looks at
Eli and goes but this is Eli do you
think that he loves Eli and I think your
answer is probably yes it is more than
he loves winning because right now Eli
is not giving them the opportunity or
even the chance to win there is no
quarterback that has had the narrative
changed more in their favor over the
years than Eli Manning Eli Manning sucks
but what about his offensive line yes
Eli Manning sucks but what about his
wide receiver yes there's no talent
Eli sucks but he's hasn't had a running
game Oh we'll get him sake won Eli sucks
and now it's but their defense sucks
that's what they're saying now but we
you know why their defense sucks because
they trade Olivia Vernon to get Kevin
Zeidler dear check for Eli Manning to
protect the quarterback I listen Eli
have to do much better to me would you
make the move I think I think at Tampa
Bay in Week three I don't I don't like
facing Todd Bowles cuz his defense is
you clicking face yeah but I love
starting rookie quarterbacks on the road
I don't want them there at the home
crowd I don't want the boos I don't want
to start slow and the Giants have always
played well in Tampa Bay it's like
really weird
I would I would put Daniel Jones in
would you for several different reasons
it provides a spark to my football team
to my Owen to football team well it then
it would be really deflating at that
point yes panic time it's probably
already panic time but it provides your
spark I think you get a little bit more
from the guys which is kind of weird to
say because I think the guys like Eli
but they also know that he's limited
if we're seeing it on the sidelines
we're seeing it watching tape didn't the
guys in the locker room see it every day
Brian I have said for three years that
Eli Manning has to go yeah and my number
one reason is are you watching the games
I don't know what's being watched I
don't get it well III think you may have
a little bit of point when you talk
about the owners that's the owners and
that's his son
well yes I can understand that like you
brought the team to Super Bowls and that
means something to some people and some
people are just absolutely loyal the
Patriots have no loyalty except for
number 12 anybody else kinda knows faded
away and what's really funny is this
right now Robert Kraft looks like a
genius that he went to Bill Belichick
and said we are not gonna get rid of
Brady right we are going to trade Jimmy
Garoppolo because Tommy boy is telling
me I have more time left yeah and he
gave more time and he's gotten two Super
Bowls in return but I absolutely think
that Robert Kraft whenever Tom Brady
eventually starts to slow down which
20:35 yeah yeah Kraft Alessi if Brady
wants to keep going Kraft will let him
go as long as he wants because they
don't know how to get rid of him at some
point it's probably gonna come down to
bill is gonna say hey if you want Tom
then I'm go I'm out I can't keep doing
this that's what I've been dreaming
about you think I mean I wouldn't know
but I don't think I just I don't see it
happening any time soon
like that was like that was a good radio
talking point two years ago and now it's
like I don't question that team anymore
if Tom can keep playing at the level you
play analysis that Mehra probably thinks
that Eli is in the same level as Tom
there's no way he can say that there's
no way he can look at his team in the
struggles that they've had and
understand that the quarterback is the
most important position in football in
and say that hey man the last three
years it was somebody other than Eli
this is the same team that took a
running back in the best quarterback
draft that we've had in maybe 20 years
well and I want to talk about that too
what do you want to say what's a Kwan
well I just think that by the time your
team gives good yep he's [ __ ] there's
a there's a point where that's my
argument against Daniel Jones by the way
as Daniel Joan give you a chance to win
right now because he can run but do I
want Daniel Jones to run a lot in this
first season and maybe get hurt but what
you're saying about say Kwan is
you draft say Kwan to be the face of the
franchise and in like two or three years
when they're finally good burnt out
that's these burnt out that's fit my
fear since I got trapped because I think
that he's a special special talent and
he ends up being Barry Sanders burnt out
he's carried the load of the franchise
and I'm not talking about just on the
football field off the field - and by
the time you get Daniel Jones up to
speed let's say it's a year from now
let's say it's two years from now
because you're not playing them now this
is a probably reason why I would play
him now because I want to make sure that
he gets up to speed they kind of jive at
the same time with say Kwan being in his
prime minister obably is now for the
next three or four years I want those
guys playing together because I spent
such a high draft pick on say Kwan I
have to get Daniel Jones in there right
now and I can't afford to lose one of
the best running backs that's come out
of college in the last 10 years because
we don't we want to show loyalty to Eli
who's past his prime at this point no
and everybody sees it except where the
God is right in the chai I just want to
say this as an Eagles fan
I want to Eli to be out there as much as
possible I would - it's not my fear my
fear is that Daniel Jones gets in there
and by the time they play the Eagles
he's got himself down a little bit of
flow and he's able to move this is what
Daniel Jones brings a live arm meaning
he's willing to whip it it's me you know
what if my quarterbacks willing to take
some you know make some mistakes and
throw the ball around he's gonna make
some great plays
he's probably make some poor plays
heartless first year but I know that
he's gonna throw the football and that
makes me excited I know right now Eli is
not willing to put himself his body on
the line to make some of those throws
and that's gonna be an issue well that's
hard for me to sell to my team I agree
because my team box is a tape - like
that team is already falling apart here
with Jim Norris Jenkins looser when
asked about the Giants defense he said
what am I supposed to cover for ten
seconds we don't have a pass rush how
are we how am I supposed to cover
someone for 10 SEC Alling up the guys on
your own team well your side of the ball
that's the thing recipe for disaster
there Jacksonville for the longest time
has been calling off their offense yeah
but it's when you start calling out your
own side of the ball if then I go it's
gonna get ugly
alright so some undercover ballers of
the week I know you have some yeah I
want to give a shout-out to
these are these are the guys we we have
the 33% I want to figure out who gave
their 133 percent this week my 133
percenters I'm going Gardner Minshew I
thought it's your boy that should
welcome to our game
I'm actually not the biggest fan of
Gardner Minshew right now just because
whenever the media latches on and
everybody loves some guy you're all then
I'm like you don't love him as much he's
getting too much attention for you it
[ __ ] kills me I don't know why but I
do that late drive the scramble the
touchdown there were reports that he was
stretching in the locker room and a
jockstrap only before the game well that
that is gonna be all against man code
right there so that makes me out to
anybody that did stuff like that yes yes
and it was not and I I'm not gonna same
however [ __ ] this is this is a safe
space is watching when you come in to
the locker when you take a shower yeah
you have a towel on okay you sit at your
locker which you don't do is turn around
and face the locker room with just a
towel on legs wide open just no you
change your clothes put your clothes on
and then if you want to have a
conversation with your laundry
then you turn don't don't be twerking in
the locker room her said gonna do that
don't be doing any of that naked I don't
want it to have any naked talk I don't
want to have guys in the jock strap
stretching know we have shorts people
had to mess with you with this no they
didn't so who was the who was the name I
don't want to say I don't I said but I
didn't like it
coy Detmer white would do stuff like oh
no I take this koi-koi do it because you
trying to be funny here why people
didn't like it but no he would ever on
this podcast
Okoye is hella so when were in practice
and Andy was he would always like coy
and AJ kind of do it at their own backup
quarterbacks nobody really care
hopefully you'll never have to play
right they would they would come out in
like an all-white like a bunny suit
almost like white long-sleeve shirt
white pants white tights
white shoes like just and just run
around practice like it was it was
hilarious at the dollar store me a lot
funnier yeah no it was not funny but
it's it's what happens is was here to
Douglas will see the naked you know
cherry was it no I'm not a big fan but
keep guessing your clothes they were on
the defensive line
Hollis Thomas
[ __ ] nailed it [ __ ] it I just I'm not
a big fan I I like guys amazing I like
guys to be close when we talk that's
what I like we have a to injury notes I
just got on the BR app James Connors
injury is manageable so you know I'm not
healthy yeah yeah
Michael gallop out two to four weeks
surgery trim meniscus just developed the
relationship with dad
but I will say this it's okay because
one of my guys I gave a hundred and
thirty three percent this week yeah
devin Smith yeah wide receiver for the
Cowboys you know back-to-back weeks
ballin I loved him coming out of Ohio
State second-round draft pick for the
Jets multiple ACL injuries looks amazing
and that was when I saw the gallop
injury I went they got the replacement
until he gets back I'm so happy for
Devin I like deviseth because I tore my
ACL in 96 and I play my entire career
meniscus all the difference like the
steps you've heard of James Andrews I
did actually yeah he did a couple of my
surgeries yes so I went to James Andrews
great doctor
old school doctor great right take care
of a bunch of NFL guys wrestling
baseball guys talk about Tommy John he
did my elbow too so I love Debbie Smith
because he this is his first touchdown
this week since 2015 I'm something he
grinded continue to have faith in
himself build the dream and now he's
finally showing some you know coming to
fruition just looks like he lost a sec
no p-speed still fast ran right past
Josh normal which to me I was I was
asking a couple guys that play with Josh
Norman and have washed him and I said
just tell me your thoughts because my
thought was this that he's good in a
defense where he can sit back and watch
but if he has to play man-to-man he has
to be they the shutdown corner that's
not if just that skill because he's not
fast right devin Smith is fast right
pass and 15 yards Norman and Xavier
Rhodes no I'm having the same concerns
about right now well Xavier bro about
Josh Tansey well the thing about Xavier
Rose is that he's nasty physical at the
line of scrimmage so you got he the
quarterback really slow yeah he just not
look he does not look fast but if he
gets his hands on you its physical at
the line of scrimmage it changes the
look for the quarterback both be
safeties at this point
I just don't know josh is gonna hit like
that now don't stay here I would think
it would hit but they don't really need
a safety well guess who makes money and
guess why you they never yeah they of
course the only other I wanted to give a
shout out to DK Metcalf I thought balled
out 133% Devin Singletary I hope his
injuries not bad and I just want to give
a shout out to Cooper cup and Emmanuel
Sanders cup coming off an ACL Sanders
coming off an Achilles to do what
they're doing in week two well O's my
mind Emmanuel Sanders I thought caught
the game-winner in the end zone if it
wasn't for the crazy ending to Chicago
Denver and then Cooper Cup I mean looked
amazing Emmanuel Sanders smaller guy
looks faster now than he did before he
got hurt smaller guy but he works the
middle of the field the Edelman type of
area in the middle of the field amongst
linebackers and safeties looks fast he
looks quick you saw him the two-point
conversion simple route that any cover
any corner in the league just see way
before it happens
he beats in about two or three yards
wide open great call I love a manual
because he came back that Achilles
injury is a beast
especially at 32 years old to come back
from here absence thirties Achilles ago
I thought you're done but I guess not
it's amazing what he was able to do who
do you think gave a hundred and thirty
three percent this way I have two guys
and I think the last two weeks and I
talked about say quanta and them just
they're gonna use him up but 107 yards
their offenses terrible not much talent
around all everybody in defense is
around the line of scrimmage
he still goes off for a hundred plus
yards in last two weeks but Dalvin cook
mmm I've been waiting for this since
he's been drafted I thought that coming
into the league he was fast
ya thought he had great vision great
lateral agility he had the breakaway
speed and he could catch the ball out of
the backfield we're starting to see
these last couple of weeks 200 over 200
yards 260 plus yards these last two
weeks combined but he's a workhorse
they're giving on 20 carries he knocks
people over nasty and he can run away a
fan he can run and at some point what
they'll get to and I think they did it
just a little bit this past week they'll
start flexing him out getting them
one-on-one with whoever he did that a
Florida State yes he can do so I asked
you yesterday if Christian McCaffrey
last week if Christian McCaffrey was the
best running back yeah I felt his Dalvin
cook the best running back in the NFL
he's just way to do this every he's
playing really really
well I still I still can't get away from
my top to say Kron and Zeke because they
would they do but Dalvin cook leggett
longevity it's all my greatness you take
a little cover camara the way that
they're playing right now especially
without Drew Brees yes I know that
Dalvin cook can carry the load running
the football 20 times a game
I'm not sure that camara can I'm just
not I'm not sure you know I came away
yesterday and we're giving up 13 carries
here in there I think that's the number
for Sean Payton I don't know they he'll
ever get more than that and he's so
valuable to you in the past game because
he presents mismatches you probably
never get more than that
I know Dalvin cook can carry the load
though and I'm starting to see a little
bit more a little bit more that
Christian McCaffrey can do the same
thing especially in the run game in
terms of WTF moments of the week I'm
amazed at some of these kicking misses
still Minnesota multiple missed kicks in
that game they lose that game by five
mhm
Tennessee missed a kick down the stretch
Indianapolis goes back to other way
scores chargers missed two kicks their
kickers been hurt their punters been
kicking he missed two yeah and they lose
by three Detroit Matt Prater missed -
you didn't miss though who's that Eddie
frickin Panero kicker for the Chicago
Bears yeah after all that after all of
the offseason where they spent all that
time trying to figure out who their
kickers gonna be any Panero goes out
there and kicks a game-winning 53-yard
kick and i want to read something that
Ingeborg got for me and i appreciate it
he scored 13 of the bears 19 points this
season so 68% of his team points his
field goals have been 38 40 52 and 53
and given data for kicker accuracy over
the last 10 years he's had a twenty nine
point four percent chance of hitting all
four outdoor clutch no problem
Eddie [ __ ] pinion beaten the odds
last year their season ended because of
the double doink they made sure that
they do that wouldn't happen again but
that's also my issue with the pair's is
it's the one part of their team right
now that looks the post strongest part
of their team now their defense is good
at the same point they did allow a
game-winning Joe
flacco drive that's right like that's
right WTF yeah they did allow them to
get the two-point conversion to lose the
game
and if it wasn't for a very questionable
roughing the passer penalty on Bradley
Chubb and then granting the away team a
timeout when there may have been point
like he hit the ground and then you
would have had to give him a timeout in
point one sense that was such [ __ ]
to me
clock who's running the clock that's
what I mean it was the away team who's
running the clock most important person
in the stadium ain't close games is the
person running a clock Bears fans well
let what happens is you if in the worst
case scenario you care kids fears left
let the referees say hey put more time
back on they stopped it that's my point
who's running the clock but good Freddie
penny arrow I'm happy for him another
thing that was WTF was the Saints
getting screwed by the refs again that
was so bleep but not that but that
that's the exact thing that the NFL said
we're not gonna do we're not gonna blow
it dad we're gonna allow the play to run
out and then we'll figure it out after
that that's that was a point of emphasis
these last couple years the one thing
and I love that cam Jordan goes into the
interview hold a locker good locker so
straight face footlocker you talked
about how that was an issue think about
some of these calls Denver Chicago that
rough in the past year and then
preemptively blowing the whistle there
was another sack that Leonard Floyd had
in the game that they called roughing
the passer it was not philadelphia
Atlanta carson wentz dives for the
two-point conversion and he's giving
himself up I don't understand their
broom and then also okay fine if he gave
himself up then the Falcons player that
dove into him afterwards is that a
person because he clearly gave himself
how do you give yourself up if you slide
and if you dive so there's nothing that
I can do as a quarterback so they deal
extra yard they blow the whistle when
he's like getting away from a sack like
he always doesn't throw down why are we
blowing the whistle there Chargers had
two touchdowns taken back San Francisco
has had four touchdowns turned back in
two games there are so many referee
Anneliese that feel like our determining
these games right now
well it is it is it solely the referees
though or is it you know what there's
some guys blocking in the back downfield
there's some guys not in the right
position because maybe they didn't place
as much in the preseason maybe these
guys aren't as disciplined because in
the CBA you can't practice blocking with
full pads on as much anymore
maybe the referees just aren't any good
a lot of different things can go on but
I think certainly is probably some
referee issue price and player issue too
it just frustrates me because apparently
the way they got out of some stuff as
they say it was a judgment call
mm-hm and then like there was the video
from Thursday night if Carolina and
Tampa Bay were like he clearly didn't
get the first down and the referee just
took the ball and moved it six inches
and gave him the first down and like
Troy Aikman was like okay and it's it's
a running joke on line where it's like
this is a forty billion dollar industry
and we have random dudes that aren't
even full time that are moving the ball
six inches and we're like first down and
that could end a game by just so much
money so many people that are betting
these game and everyone's going should
we get rid of replay and I'm on the
other side where it's like should we
just do everything really let me ask you
this because the replays now they can
replay pass in the first offensive and
defense and to me even now did they
replay them they still got it wrong
always know like huh that's pass
interference oh that's the offense to
push oh that's a guy grabbing someone
else's arm up like the how does one have
failed that was pass interference
yesterday on the Eagles on Julio and
they did was okay with it
I mean I just don't understand why they
are not getting it right that's the
purpose there was a Vikings touchdown
called back because when they look to
see if there's pass interference on one
guy they actually found it on a guy
that's right and that's not the intent
of the rule you can find it what if what
if you say hey man they sort of test now
but I think the offensive lineman held
on often I know that's not one of the
things you can rule but I mean look
there's holding on every play you're
right like if there's a 75 yard Dalvin
cook run should Matt Lafleur throw the
challenge [ __ ] and be like I think well
the offensive lineman commits holding if
it's an accrued
situation I would certainly think I
could do I don't think you can I think
you can review it but if that if it ever
gets down to that absolutely yep
someone's holding it's just which one
one of the five guys up front one of
those guys um we're talking about teams
have a chance I just want to wrap up
with Miami Dolphins one time on top of
that we don't make that statement and
say and I want to talk about the
Dolphins if you want to say the Dolphins
you have to say we're talking about a
team that have no chance in hell of
winning more than four games they have
lost by a differential of 92 points in
the first two games yeah the amount of
points that they've allowed which i
think is a hundred and two is the most
since the 73 Saints mm-hmm they are on
pace right now to give up 816 points
this year which would set the all-time
NFL record never had it wasn't just that
there that Ryan Fitzpatrick looks like
he has no chance on offense mhm it's not
just that it's that the that both of the
Ravens and the Patriots have been able
to do whatever they want it it's the
second half where it seems like lifeless
where the other team is not even running
anymore on a pick six they're like
walking it in it's laughable
it's literally laughable guys are I mean
in NFL it's rare and I think you kind of
see it in Baltimore a little bit some
time with Patrick Mahone but it's just
not rich it's rare that guys are just
wide open no one within 20 yards of them
you see it all the time against the dog
I don't know the question to me would be
did you guys practice this is this what
you practiced because I have to imagine
Brian Flores has them in the the
walkthroughs and the meetings I honestly
thought the defense was a little bit
better in the first half I thought they
were defending a B and Josh Gordon well
I'll save you and Howard played a little
bit better but then it reaches a point
where they lose hope and then it's just
like anvil like avalanche what do you
tell your team what do you what do you
tell your team because I all I hear
every Monday is well two more guys say
they want to get trade
Mika Fitzpatrick and Kenyan Drake
apparently are being shopped out of
their their first-round pick from last
year and running back that everyone
clearly seizes the most talented on this
team yeah I mean I just I don't
understand it's a tank
III get that part but Eggbert was joking
earlier the Josh Rosen and Fitzpatrick
are on the bench like who's going in
next 14 weeks left though this is not
week 12 week 14 you have 14 weeks left
how does that work how do those meetings
go I've been on the team in San
Francisco I talk about all the time we
were only six hmm and I remember those
meetings and I used to be sitting there
like yeah we ain't gonna do none of
these things all these things we talking
about in here all the things you're
saying go ten yards and cut this way to
offensive lines gonna be a double team
up to the linebacker we do none of those
things good we do none of them well what
are we doing at practice and we would go
to practice and I would be like well
yeah well here's why we don't do them
well we suck at practice against the
scout team in the place that we design
on paper we have the scout team in the
exact position we want them for the
perfect block and we suck at doing that
we were bad at that we were bad at
practicing and I have to believe this
team if you got some of the best players
on a bad team saying you want to be out
of there
the rest of the team has to be looking
around like hey what time to check
supposed to be here do you know how
everyone goes happens once a year do we
think that Alabama or Clemson yeah
couldn't be at a Miami Dolphin right
right do we think that mattered a high
school could beat the Miami Dolphin no
no but it would be interesting why they
can't beat them but it would be
interesting to watch I'll tell you they
do have five star quarterback Bryce
young yeah that counts for nothing
against the NFL team but I'll tell you
this I think that Clemson cuz you know
what sucks too is Kenny Stills is
balling yeah and they got rid of him and
it's not like the guys they're getting
rid of her not doing well well he has a
quarterback this throwing the ball down
the field that also has a a pro bono on
one side another guy fuller that can run
speed down the field too so line for
Cowboys Dolphins it's already 21
I've never seen because the interesting
thing is when the Browns went Owen 16
the smart move was to bet on the side of
the Browns because the number kept
getting bigger but the Browns were
keeping every ghost Gary number they had
miles Garrard they had some spark on
that team yeah I don't see anything and
I've never seen I remember there was one
game where you guys play the Texans and
Derek Carr mm-hm and you were David Carr
and you were favored by 21 points at
home
yeah and that was the game where Brian
Dawkins had a punt return for a
touchdown interception of the sack at
the at the vet at the vet yeah and I
remember the stories that week of I have
never seen a team favored by 21 the New
England Patriots were the first team
this past week to ever win and cover the
spread
favored as a 16 and a half points or
more on the road I thought that and they
won and they they almost covered the
spread with their defense by a Jif I
thought that uh in my mind I took the
Dolphins in the point because actually
one of my shows I took dolphins in the
points because I'm like it's 19
there's no way luckily switched out and
I did not take them I said well Bill
Thomas he's not gonna run it up when one
of his former coach I can call the
timeout with four minutes left Willie
damn right he will I think that overalls
or anything else from week one what did
you think about Jalen Ramsey and
screaming at each other in the sidelines
I need your advice is that two guys just
being competitive because to me in my
mind I never went together my head coach
like that right I never want to show him
up on the side I don't want to do that I
respect him too much and maybe it was an
Andy Reid thing and maybe was just too I
liked him so much and I respected him
but I never want to be Jalen Ramsey on
the sidelines screaming at my head coach
like that I'm trying to find the one
part of the clip where Marone said
something and it caused two other
players to jump up yeah yeah yeah
what could Marone have said that caused
two other players to immediately stand
up and point to the sidelines and go
stand over there yeah what could because
I'm seeing some people like Dianna
Rossini tweeted out listen he's from the
he's from Harlem he's from the Bronx
hehe was willing to fight anybody and
I'm like Oh Marone he didn't look like
he shot a fight and so my thing is is
yeah but people from those areas will
also say any right
what could Marone have said to ramsey
that cause those other two dudes to jump
up and and feel the need to defend
ramsey in my world there's yes take me
to your world two things that you can
say and i don't know that the coach
would say this to one of his best
players is fu if you if you say fu like
we're in a heater fu now we're now we're
not having an argument we're fighting
now we're not talking about no we're
having we're having a fist [ __ ] ass so
that's one so after you that that
probably would be the one thing and I
just don't know that coaches are saying
that it to me it didn't look like he
said that either so I don't have a clue
what he said maybe he said he couldn't
say you suck he could mean just he can't
say anything crazy because he's your
best player your defense side of the
ball have you ever seen a cut the F up
what's maybe there what's the biggest
coach you're telling me that if a coach
walked over said shut the [ __ ] up that
the rest of team like get the [ __ ] out
of here
cuz to me now sideline say an F you were
shut the [ __ ] out that big of well no
I'll tell you this one of the biggest
fights that t/o and Donovan had was
because Donovan says shut the [ __ ] up to
TL hmm right that's in the middle of a
game that's in a heated battle that's at
the beginning of it that was the first
series of the game they had a
conversation and I always think it's the
bubbling up of something that's been an
issue for a long time yeah they're
losing in their average that's what it
is
I think Jalen Ramsey's sitting there
being like I'm not paid you didn't give
me a new contract your offense I have to
go through this [ __ ] for another year
yeah where we got to carry you guys
yeah and hold deshaun Watson to 12
points and hope that you guys can figure
out a way to score at the end he's O's
bubbling up and if you're gonna get
angry at me for anything go focus on
your offense yeah because I'm holding
I'm holding DeAndre Hopkins to under 55
yards receiving and you're over there
trying to squeeze a field goal at a
gardener man
and they were trying to I think the
biggest part of that him being upset was
that he wanted maroon to challenge
Marone to challenge a ball catch whether
it was a catch or not he thought it was
incomplete
oh that's and he didn't challenge it and
so I think that's where it all started
from where it went and how you got there
oh I want to know listen when your team
is bad
let's say and you hold a good offense
the thirteen point you started to point
some fingers a little bit listen
Ramsey's gonna be a really good
Tennessee Titan next year he's out of
there you think he's out of there
Westbrook you're the [ __ ] man I'm
gonna see you in two days um we're gonna
do that again
hey man you listen you gotta give some
effort you at least gotta meet me
halfway fifty percent at least I was
over the silver no you got that's not
the halfway this is oh yeah see see that
trying to help me all right so our
Eagles meter we are both lower than we
ever thought we would be four point five
for me man five point one we are gonna
do more questions with Westbrook on
Wednesday that comes out Thursday so we
can learn more about you I think that
might be a stable going for do you
really want to know more about me man
I'm a little afraid it's like opening
Pandora's box so hit us up on the
Twitter at left go show do not tag
Westbrook because I don't want him to be
surprised then the question to me I'll
let you know that no that wouldn't no no
no we're gonna surprise you for
Westbrook for Inger in the back doing
great research today I am the lef koe
man and we will see if the Browns are
one in one on Wednesday or Thursday
oh and [ __ ] - hey what do you think I
don't make predictions about games that
have already happened right in the
Browns but okay I think Trevor Simeon
has the ball with a chance at the end
and can't get [ __ ] done
miles caret ends it which we'll find out
see you guys later peace
you
[Music]